I come from a glacier country and I come
from Norway I come from you know
mountains and snow and ice
the mountains around the Tibetan Plateau
hold more ice than any other place on
the planet except the northern South
Pole now this ice is melting faster than
any other ice on the planet and the
Tibetan Plateau is essentially the
source point of all of Asia's major
rivers
people downstream these rivers numbering
and over billion
I wanted to both look at the immediate
effects up in the highlands but also see
you know how does that connect with
people living 500 miles downstream I
felt very much when I was among these
people Tibetan nomads that in a way I
was seeing the last chapter in their
long story essentially because the
pasture lands are disappearing due to
climate change in cities like Delhi
India you are already seeing desperate
water shortages these people their day
can start at 3:30 in the morning to get
in line to wait for water
here we're in Dhaka capital of
Bangladesh I woke up one morning I get
out of my hotel door and I step in to
half a meter water the entire city I
have flooded so basically halfway walked
halfway swam around the city trying to
get images of you know people who are
dealing with their city mean flooded
this is people Natacha trying to shore
up an eroding embankment stories to do
with the environment are often tricky
because they can be very hard to
visualize change is happening you might
not see them from one week to the next
but it's something that will have a
great impact of several billion people
so it's a great challenge but
nonetheless I think it's very important
that we use photography to talk about
these issues